so this is a topic that our two speakers
have been discussing back and forth as
he saw reflected in their talk so it's
really exciting to have a chance to have
a more open-ended discussion as well as
the talks we vary so I'll be keeping a
queue of questions or you know calling
up people addresses but will maybe get
things rolling with a question of my own
so I think one issue that was crucial in
both of your talks was the question of
how does it distinguish between what
should be fundamental in physics or what
should be features that the laws are
fundamental geometry versus what can be
derived or what should be treated as
less what I'm alone I think one way of
trimming at that is thinking of the
kinds of resources that open up given
different answers my questions if you
treat something as fundamental or is the
future of the laws you're committed to a
certain account of it whereas if you
treat something is not done so in
general we see all sorts of ways in
which the phenomenological features of
the world are not directly reflected in
the laws so one possibility then is that
you can get different kinds of
explanations of those features if you
treat them as perhaps due to initial
conditions of particular types of
systems versus laws so I think this was
a theme that was president both your
talks I think you seem to take very
different lives on this we're assuming
about that there's a way of putting time
Direction is a fundamental feature in
the physical geometry
that was something that you you think is
incredibly appealing and motivates this
reformation of the standard ways of
thinking about geometry whereas I think
David you were pushing more towards
thinking of certain features as derived
maybe there's just one initial point of
clarification about that there's there's
there's a way of looking at what Tim has
done as a piece of mathematics which i
think is neutral between these two and I
think it's a beautiful piece of
mathematics and and you know really
intriguing really interesting it seems
to me I agree with a lot of the claims
about this making notions of openness
more intuitive and so on and so forth so
there's a huge swath of that which it
seems to me is neutral is neutral
between these views the the question is
whether the the I mean I'm just jumped
in should I just jump so so so there's
here's a way to start a discussion if
there is this fundamental directedness
that tim is thinking about the dynamical
laws don't latch on to it okay that is
the dynamical laws of classical
mechanics the Schrodinger equation so on
and so forth are time reversal symmetric
okay they could be formulated in either
do you know that is they allow processes
in both directions in in exactly the
same way given that that's the case if
you want to give an account of say if
you want to give a satisfying account of
how I know there's a chair in the room
the existence of the chair plays a
dynamical role in my coming to say I
mean a full explanation would involve
you know neuroscience which we don't
have at our disposal yet and so on and
so forth but presumably the existence of
the chair would play a causal role in my
coming to say there's a chair in the
room whereas on a view
like Tim's one of the puzzles is that we
make these judgments this is before this
as Tim as Tim did in his talk it was
right these judgments these judgments we
make are physical acts that we do are
physical events we write down the
judgments we make utterances that
express the judgments so on and so forth
those are coming to make the utterances
that we do are coming to write down the
inscriptions that we write down are
going to require an explanation
presumably in terms of the laws of
motion okay so that the direction of
time being what it is on a view like
Tim's isn't going to play the role in
our judging that this was before this
that say there being a chair in the room
is going to play in our judging that
that there's a chair in the room so the
worry is that the the worry is that
positing a fundamental direction in the
way Tim wants to do leaves it
disconnected in a way that ought to be
worrying it seems to me from from the
from the way this information get from
questions of the way this information
gets to us
good so there there many points let me
let me try and take let me just point
out some things linguistically which I
think are important and can can mask
what I take to be the kind of gap
between us so even Chris when you began
you said look there are some things that
are explained by the laws and some
things don't follow from the laws but
you also need initial conditions right
that was you said that you got it on
tape
right initial conditions the initial and
initial conditions is important right it
was sort of thought to be a great
triumph in the Scientific Revolution
that we gave up what we're called
theological explanations which were
explanations that appeal to the future
in favor of mechanical explanations this
is another thing we're just historically
we're gonna canticle men right no no no
explanation always runs from the past to
the future okay now if you don't think
there's a fundamental distinction
physical distinction between the
direction from past to future in the
direction from future to past it's a
little bit mysterious I mean this is
what this is what Hugh price gets
himself into because he really believes
that he thinks there's no distinction so
all that talk of initial conditions
isn't can't mean what one initially or
you it's going to be it's going to be
problematized the talk of causation gets
problematized if you think clauses have
to precede their effect the talk of how
do we get the information think of the
word how do we acquire information it's
time directed it means at an earlier
time we don't have the information and
at a later time we do have the
information the other thing is called
forgetting so the time directedness of
all our vocabulary and therefore all of
our explanations that use normal
vocabulary right it's very hard to
imagine extracting it and seeing what
would be left of what we
of as an explanation at all now does
this show up in the physics whether a
couple simple points when David says the
the laws of physics are time reversible
he means something by it but he doesn't
mean by that time reversible they're not
right we know they're not because CP
violation
so if you ask me I look at the physics
does that your sister dragon of mine the
answer is sure it does no no no but we
doubt that that has to do with the way
we make judgments about the time order I
guess all right but it but it's the the
physics that I mean of course that makes
the physics from your point of view more
mysterious because you're saying gee
when I look really deep into these
equations even for K ons or whatever I
decide gee there does seem to be a
directionality in there now you know a
lot of this and again this is a little
technical but if you start with
classical physics you start with
Newtonian mechanics it's a second-order
theory in time you take second
derivatives right take it your
fundamental dynamics in terms of
accelerations and the second derivatives
of course are invariant under the first
derivatives are if you do quantum
mechanics strugglers equations first
first order in time and you have to
implement time reversal you have to take
the complex conjugate okay it's not so
soon and you could say that's just a
reflection that there is a
directionality here now David's point
which is correct right one of the points
he's worried about about statistical
explanation that we all agree is that
physics as we now have it if it allows
the glass to fall off the shelf and
splatter on the ground it allows for a
situation we would call the water
collecting itself in the glass and
jumping back on the desk and we wanted
an understanding about why we see one
all the time and why we don't see the
other all the time but notice the way I
just described that is a temporally
asymmetric description right because
falling down is different from jumping
up they differ with respect to what with
respect to the direction right so I
don't really see you know if you did
things my way I'm now gonna come to the
question you were asking it is true if
you did things my way there would be a
task so employment for academics or
somebody
to rewrite to see how to rewrite all of
the dynamics that's been done in terms
of standard topological structure in
these terms which would be it not
extremely non-trivial task there there
are some reasons to think it would be an
interesting thing to do I will just you
know wave my hand at this which is that
this structure allows you to deal with
discrete spaces spaces that aren't
continuous spaces where the lines end up
having only finitely many points with
all the same analytical structure so if
you think and a lot of people do think
for good or bad reasons that space-time
really is discrete at blank skin and not
a continuum I've got a gadget that that
you can work with and carry over if you
rewrite the continuum stuff in these
terms you can carry that over directly
and deal with the discrete case and you
get automatic cut-offs and stuff like
that right so you'll deal with ultra
violet things and blah blah blah so
there is you know there's there it would
be an interesting thing you know I mean
I think it opens up a range of
possibilities that would require a
tremendous amount of investigation which
I'm not going to be even capable of you
know intellectually much less in any
other way but yeah ultimately I would
think if I'm right the laws of physics
oughta take a particularly appealing a
nice form when expressed in this
particular mathematical language because
if I'm right this mathematical language
is is more directly representing the
fundamental physical structure
well as I said III don't think I mean
this but which time-reversal do mean if
you mean the jumpy up stuff yeah I think
things can still probably still jump up
but if you're asking if I just look at
the laws of physics do they look time
reversal invariant I think the answer is
I think they already don't once you go
to a first-order theory right I have to
do stuff to implement time reversal it's
not well this is funny because when you
start who had opposite sides of this but
they're there I mean a couple of things
because what Tim said was very rich the
the first of all I I don't know what
Hugh is up to but I mean if somebody is
denying all to get not not you yeah Hugh
probably sorry it can't be that he's
denying altogether that there is a time
I symmetry he's denying that it's
fundamental that's what the discussion
is about I take it I mean whatever you
price says leave that to him it
certainly wouldn't be something I would
be tempted to say there's a dispute
about that the only dispute here is not
whether there's a distinction okay but
whether it's built into the fundamental
structure of space-time or not so of
course the resources that you rightly
pointed to as being presupposed by our
ordinary English locations had better be
locatable in the world okay and and of
course they are you know and and there's
nothing about a denial that they're
fundamental that carries with it a
denial that these things can be located
in the world and of course it's the
position of somebody who denies that
their fundamental that they can
nonetheless be located in the world just
like tables and chairs and universities
can be can be located in the world so it
doesn't so I'm not sure how it helps to
say gee are ordinary are ordinary
language is just fused with
time directed terms yes of course it is
those had better be referring to some
feature of the way the world is there's
nothing in their profusion in our
language that indicates that the thing
they have to be pointing to is something
fundamental as opposed to something like
let me just make a quick point here look
the notion of a university is not
suffuse din our language in anything
like the same way right if it were if I
found that for almost every verb I used
I had to I had to agree the universities
to make sense of right I'd really worry
about whether I could think of
universities as derivative right because
the question is what are using to get
from the fundamentals of derivatives so
it's just that's a even existed yeah
there's sometimes why don't you there's
something much more ubiquitous yeah
about time directedness and then there
is about University and I think it's a
fundamental role in certain kinds of
explanations and as I say and what we're
classically considered yeah under like
we are and that different dynamic thing
right that's absolutely right also just
the thing about because this is maybe
interesting and maybe at something I
haven't heard before from Tim although
maybe I'm just miss reading him
these are V the question of say whether
one what to think of the Schrodinger
equation is time reversal symmetric
right we've sort of I guess danced
around in circles because I remember us
being on opposite sides of exactly this
argument once what everybody agrees
about so there's some dispute in the
literature which I think at the end of
the day is mostly semantical about
exactly what one should mean by time
reversal symmetric but what everybody
agrees is true about the Schrodinger
equation is for example that for every
probability distribution of particle
locations in the nonrelativistic case
there is the exact time reversed
probability distribution of particle
locations that's associated with another
solution to those equations of motion so
as Tim said in terms of talk about
whether the water can jump up from the
ground
and put itself back in the glass all of
the theories that we take seriously
quantum mechanics classical mechanics so
on and so forth
whether they are fundamentally
formulated in terms of the first
derivative or a second derivative agree
on that okay second of all it's not it's
not the sense in which the Schrodinger
equation something like the Schrodinger
equation fails to be time reversal
symmetric I don't see any reason why
that has to be taken as gesturing
towards a fundamental directedness of
time all you need by that all you need
mean by that in order to become here and
is to take a very explicitly and
manifestly time-reversal asymmetric
theory like the grw theory of collapses
all you need mean by that is that is
that all the collapse events line up in
a certain way but but it doesn't imply a
distinction between you know between
this set of events and the same set of
events flipped over so there were two
things to say about this thing one is
the sense in which say something like
the Schrodinger equation might fail to
be time-reversal symmetric on a certain
construal of what time reversal symmetry
means a construal that I once argued for
that's not going to affect these
judgments about whether the water can
jump back into the glass and so on and
so forth second of all even if it's
granted that that it fails to have that
mathematical property I don't see any
reason to think that that we think of
that mathematical property as gesturing
towards some feature of the structure of
what we're calling the background arena
itself but let me ask Tim so Tim you
seem to take up Chris's suggestion well
I don't know if you did or not
Chris seemed to be asking do you think
this view of the structure of space and
time the one that you have is going to
force changes in it do you think that he
seemed to be asking do you think the
existing structure of physical laws say
the Schrodinger
or the Dirac equation or something like
that is going to turn out to be
incompatible with your idea about the
structure of space-time but it's going
to force and it seemed like you said yes
or mein I mean incompatible you're using
some mathematical resources to write
down these equations right in all the
standard cases you're using a background
manifold differentiable manifold right
okay so if you're gonna say all right
I'm gonna switch to a different
mathematical language that doesn't have
those resource I'm gonna have to sort of
rewrite things know whether when the
rewriting is done right it reads to what
looks like a substantial difference it
might go up in terms of prediction Russ
empirical predictions or not right I
don't know okay Farren right good it's
but the work you know would have to be
done you have to trace it out and see
good good good good
nope it it it the entire theory look the
entire theory in fact the you know the
Archimedean axiom you would have to add
in addition to it I can give you linear
structures because the the fundamental
geometrical thing that's doing all the
work is just a linear order I could have
in some infinitesimals I could violate
the axiom of art Archimedes when I put
metrics on this stuff it's very very
very weak so I mean your thought that G
is is there something scary the answer
is no and actually it gives rise to a
tremendous variety of what you think of
as an exotic geometry that's right it's
just a standard topology just again the
notion of a line is highly derivative in
standard topology and the interesting
thing about it let me just make a
comment there when I had that picture of
and I had to line up here you'll notice
that in the definitions in standard
geometry the way you even get to a curve
is by a continuous map from the real
line into the space that definition
privileges the structure of the real
line right so suppose I thought they
were infinitesimal suppose I had a
richer a richer linearly ordered
structure than even the reals right
suppose I did non-standard analysis
that's the standard definitions
they're the ones who as it were
surreptitiously restrict themselves
definitionally to things that are
actually generated out of the structure
of the set of real numbers mine's much
more open than that actually so what
what happens in my case is I then have
to say alright let's restrict ourselves
to Archimedean linear structures right
once I've got a metric I can define what
it is for it to be Archimedean and so on
but in terms of the basic definitions
they actually have very exotic
instances which are you know give rise
to interest instructions
right right right yeah that's a really
good question
yeah yeah I mean Finnair is is even a
lot to what you're writing down to right
you're writing them down on so yeah if
you go back to the classical case and
actually I mentioned at the time you
know this little caveat that I that I
put in that of course classical
particles aren't going to be enough to
build tables and chairs out of and so on
and so forth that that's that's even
more important than them might have been
apparent well while I was reading it
yeah it seems to me that that if you
were to pursue stick to the classical
taste for the moment you say look I have
this I have a case event of a
Hamiltonian on a background Euclidean
space it gives rise to flat
three-dimensional Euclidean appearances
in scare quotes and then you have a
claim that if the first thing is true
then it seems unavoidable that this
other Hamiltonian on a background curved
space is also going to produce flat
Euclidean appearances good what does
that suggest
what's the necessary condition for
producing flat Euclidean appearances I
take it the necessary condition must be
something like the the distribution of
matter on the background space in such
that a coordinate is a
of the manifold exists okay where the
Hamiltonian where it's governed by a
Hamiltonian that takes this form okay
now you ask gee what kind of features of
these trajectories is it going to be in
virtue of which it's the case that some
coordinate ization exists on which the
Hamiltonian would look like this the
only available the only available
structure you have left is the
topological structure of these
trajectories the extent to which they're
knotted or intersect or something like
that and it looks on the face of it as
if that's likely to be much much too
sparse a structure that is there are
going to be too many ways of choosing
coordinates where you can get it to obey
any equation you want okay certainly for
example if the world consists of one
such particle one such path through the
through the manifold and if the path
doesn't happen to intersect itself or to
knock itself which such paths can do
then it's clear you can get it to obey
any equation you want okay by an
appropriate change of coordinates so
that's gonna be really bad okay so you
need a much richer topological structure
than that in order to get any
constraints on what equations this is
obeying you probably need something like
a field structure okay with a field
structure you have something going on at
every point okay
you have much much richer set of
topological relations and it begins to
be I actually went and spoke to some
topologists about this and they said
look they said look you shouldn't be you
shouldn't get pessimistic so quickly
because you have no idea how many
topologically different varieties of
knots there are in three-dimensional
space and there and actually it's not
obvious that there isn't enough
structure there to do that but it's also
not far from clear that it is and this
is apparently a question about topology
that nobody even Ramone
he knows the answer - but but there
might be an interesting argument
complicit in all this that the whole
structure wouldn't make sense without
some kind of plenum okay without a field
structure or something like that where
you get a much richer set of topological
relations but anyway this question about
it being written on the air is very
relevant I take it on a view like the
one I was pursuing here now you might
want to pursue this even further and
derive topological structures I have no
idea how to do that that is physically
tim has an idea of how to do it
mathematically but if you were just as
come to rest at a differentiable
manifold like I was doing yeah all that
seems to be available is the topological
structure of the stuff that's
distributed over it and there's a real
not highly non-trivial very interesting
mathematical question about what would
suffice to uniquely pick out such and
such a Hamiltonian or such and such a
set of appearances it might be that this
is a reason that that we haven't
stumbled over before why the world you
know why why things like what why worlds
like ours wouldn't make sense without
there being fields I don't know but
that's a really good question can I can
I actually just make a comment because I
think this is also a place where we
become at things from slightly different
directions when David wrote down always
was in terms of coordinates right he
wrote down his Hamiltonian to it and
then and then it arose that the
condition was well interrogation if
there exists the coordinate Rustom in
which right right and if you think about
you know your curved space that gives
rise in the way you were saying to
Euclidean appearances of course what
would be weird about it is that the
Hamiltonian would be very strangely
variant I mean it thought of in terms of
the background curved geometry
it would be just fluctuating around in
kind of inexplicable ways I'm going to
depend on how the background geometry
right right but look you were doing it
for an arbitrary you would say it for an
arbitrary case absolutely right I mean
look what my own approach to this and
this is actually part of where I ended
up doing this thing is I don't like to
think in terms of
coordinates at all because I think
coordinates are always drift coordinates
aren't physically real right I I would
like to put into my Hamiltonian as it
were physical quantities not coordinates
and and and if I use coordinates like
say if I'm doing special relativity and
I usable rents coordinates I use those
coordinates I justify the the picking of
those coordinates by the symmetries in
the space but I think the geometry of
the space is what's fundamental and it's
in terms of the geometry of the space
that I then argue that these are nice
coordinates right and maybe I'm not
surprised that the Hamiltonian takes a
pretty form in terms of these
coordinates because these coordinates
already adapted to the fundamental
geometry of the space now the way David
thinks about things he's sort of
thinking of the coordinates first and so
that if you think if you think the
geometry is arising from appearances and
you would understand the appearances in
terms of the existence of coordinates
we're back again to what's with the
complaint wait hang on a second yeah
there's there right so there's I mean if
there's a way there's a way in which I
agree with Tim's characterization I
guess up till the last line that is it's
definitely the case that Tim that
there's a sense in which Tim is starting
with the background geometry and I'm
starting with the dynamics I'm starting
with the Hamiltonian to say I'm starting
with coordinates doesn't seem fair
likely we're just saying you know that
what what Chris's question quickly led
to is oh the real dynamical laws are
going to are going to take the form of
some claims about the topology of the
distribution of matter and fields or
something like that it's going to be
then deducible that given that topology
that that you know that one of the
features of such and such a topology is
a guarantee that there exists a
coordinate system that has such and such
properties but it doesn't seem fair to
say I'm starting out with coordinates it
does seem fair and I think it is a deep
difference
between our approaches that that you
know your Spade gets turned as it were
at the level of geometry and mine does
at the level of dynamics that's right
but have we have we suppose that I don't
want to hijack that well we just quickly
so suppose I just I wanted to press you
once more on this question that we
started with soap oh I guess things
might come out several ways but suppose
that in your words once we rewrite
physics in your mathematical language we
don't come out with what we were you
were calling a substantively different
physics then then is there a worry or am
i misunderstanding something of the form
G if that's the way it comes out if
we've still got these time reversal
symmetric equations in the sense that we
were discussing and so on and so forth
and somebody says G on that kind of a
view then our impression of time being
directed doesn't have anything to do
with the fact of x being directed that
the fact of x being directed on this
kind of a view doesn't play any role in
explaining our impression that x
directed because the thought is the only
thing that could explain impressions
like that is something dynamical and if
it comes out without these substantive
changes there won't be any sense in
which the dynamics is latching on to
this direction yeah I guess I don't yeah
I don't agree I mean look there's the
the sense of lack of time direction and
we're just going back it that you were
worried about in time and chance that we
agree about if there are folly cups
they're jumpy cups and you know my point
was yeah and on the face of it a falling
cup is just physically different than a
jumpy cup and the difference is what's
happening earlier and what's happening
later right I mean then the fall a cup
the earlier stage is up here and the
later stage is down here and now the
fact that a physics that allows the one
in terms of its laws that their
solutions models of it that allows the
one Oh
allows the other one okay that's an
interesting observation I don't see that
that observation goes any distance to
suggesting that the directionality isn't
there in fact the way I normally
describe it is in these directional
terms looks lolly cups are different
than jumping comes the question of why
do we have the impression how do I know
you know did the right hand go first or
the second I mean I take it the story
about that is going to be again a kind
of causal story about about sound waves
coming from this snap into my ear
affecting my neural state a later one
coming affecting my neural state getting
a final neural state doing computations
over that blah blah blah to me that's
all time there everything I just said
was time direct no I'd if I reversed
that it's unlike you today and I always
step out of my ears and so what let
those register the fact that maybe this
won't be something that you find
bothersome or anything like that yeah
the role it plays so it seems fair to
say that the role it's playing in the
causal explanation the role the
directedness of time is playing in the
causal explanation is as it were as a
condition of the possibility of causal
explanation yeah right in place that's
why I'm so puzzled it's very unlike the
role that say the existence of the
lectern is playing in the explanation of
my impression that there's electronics
so that I don't understand so wait so
the lectern as a physical object has a
geometrical structure in space and that
geometrical structure plays a role in
explaining why the light bounces off of
it and by the structure of the optical
array that goes into your eye right Bob
Loblaw right that pair of events had a
structure in time right it has a
geometrical structure in time no no no
wait but - but wait okay a minute ago it
sounded like you were it sounded like
you were saying and you were nodding
your head when I said this that that the
role of the directedness of time is
playing in these explanations that the
fundamental directedness of time is
playing is just in making a causal
explanation as possible in the first
place
you were appealing to the fact that that
if you don't say what happened earlier
and what happened later I don't
understand it to be
a causal explanation right so it was the
just maybe if I said just I misspoke
okay I do believe it plays that
fundamental role which is why trying to
eliminate it or recover it houses me but
I don't I'm not committed to the just I
mean I just gave you an example that so
you would say okay I think those events
had a geometrical structure in
space-time just the way the lectern you
think has and that geometrical structure
plays a role in explaining what your
percept how you perceived it and why you
came to the judgment of which was
earlier and later sure I mean it there's
that there's that part as well right so
it doesn't disappear entirely into the
background it's it's such a funny
question I don't know how you ever
managed to lose it I mean you're sort of
aware all the time of things happening
in a certain order right I mean you
could tell me who went first and who
went later in giving their presentations
and I'm not you know the idea you know
the the problem about the center of mass
was it's actually is a well-defined
location but there's nothing physical in
that location right I don't you know the
world is presented to us so there's a
piece of methodology here that maybe I
should explain the world is presented to
us as having certain kinds of structure
right before we do science it has to be
because it's on the basis of those
presentations that we have something to
do science about right if we have some
input to our science if it wasn't you
know if the world was a blank to us
initially before I had physics I would
never develop physics it's presented to
us
offhand as having three spatial
dimensions right and no more for example
now that might turn out to be wrong all
right so if string Theory's right maybe
they're these little
tiny dimensions blah blah blah David's
right it's a whole different story much
more complicated story but at least
initially is presented to us as having
three spatial dimensions and when we
start to do physics we do it assuming
there are three spatial dimensions is
what Newton does and he uses Euclidean
geometry and blah blah blah it's
presented to us as unfolding in time
ordered in time now I don't see how that
the question isn't how do I find time
the question is how did you ever lose it
in first place now sometimes people lost
it because they they wrote down some
equations right I mean really they lost
it they wrote down some equations some
second-order time equations then they
said look if I take T two minus T in
these equations they still hold okay
that's a kind of very esoteric way to
lose track of time or the direction of
time it seems to me but I don't see any
difficulty I mean I I don't see any
difficulty locating it in the sense that
we all make judgments of time word or
all the time
and there's a central tour so my idea is
look the world presents us in a certain
way the right thing is you you make
adjustments to that initial presentation
as is necessary by argument and by
further observation you have to start
with the manifest image and then you
adjust it and I just never thought there
was any argument that we ought to adjust
it by throwing the direction of time out
right and if you don't throw it out then
it's you know it's all around you
everywhere unlike centers of mass which
I really can't you know I mean for all I
know the center of mass of some you know
system is actually sitting right you
know right there and there's no way I'm
gonna look right there and find it but I
don't see how the analogy right the the
time ordering of the world has presented
to us is always with us we can't get rid
of it the sense as I said you know this
so David has a puzzle let me just maybe
this little David has a kind of puzzle
we all have the following impression
that right now I can make decisions and
carry them out that will have an effect
and influence on what I eat tonight and
I can't do a damn thing about what I ate
last night
and those two meals are as it were
symmetrically ordered with respect to
now except with respect to the
directionality right now from David's
point of view it's a bit of a puzzle why
that should be so mm-hmm right why this
big difference for me look time goes
that I mean you know not so much of a
puzzle if you think causation has you
know temporal priority orderings in it
that nothing I can do now couldn't have
any causal effect on my past in them so
you know the the the pret the present
missandei Vic witness of directionality
of time right is something that one one
ought to be much more shocked I think
then people are when physicists come
along and say you know it's all just a
no good I mean there are these kind of I
mean David doesn't say it this way so I
don't want to I don't want to put words
in his mouth but girdle does I mean
they're a bunch of people who say look
there's just it's an illusion time is an
illusion time is they go content time is
produced by the human Faculty of sensory
perception right I mean you should be
astonished by that I'm saying normal
stuff I'm saying you know time passes it
goes a certain way we're all getting
older all the time you know that's a
physical fact
in our language yes it's something like
that yeah so of course you're absolutely
right about not not only is the normal
thought that that up and down is a sort
of fundamental direction at all you just
face but that up and down or as it were
the same direction everywhere or so
that's where you got the idea because oh
gee if the earth is round why don't the
people at the Antipodes fall off right
so Galan was always that way and that's
why the earth had to be sitting on a
elephant on a turtle and then mortar you
know you kept having to add Turtles
because down was always that way and you
needed something supporting it okay so
sure you could be you could generalize
off of your local conditions in a fairly
natural way but that turns out to be
pretty bad now that particular error
about down nests for say even Aristotle
where he made down toward the center of
the universe and so the people on the
Antipodes are fine and you don't need
any turtles and elephants underneath to
keep it from falling right because it's
all going to be
tracted here you know that was a good
solution to that I would say that upness
and down Nastase ubiquitous role and say
the notion of causation right I mean
there are lots of cases where you can
you know I don't need to indicate which
way was up in which way was down as it
were to figure out what caused what but
if I tell you something but I don't give
you the time order in which they happen
you might say I can't tell what's
causing what cuz you're not telling me
what what's first and what's later so
the sense in which the direction of time
is very deeply embedded in a lot of
fundamental explanatory notions
I think is qualitatively quite different
than upness and Downers
well wait there's a couple of
presuppositions there that are worth
unpacking if if something like general
relativity is true on on versions of
cosmology that we sometimes currently
entertain there may or may not be a time
on the other side of the entropy minimum
that that you're talking about so and
I'm not sure that the difference between
Tim and me can easily be characterized
in terms of how much we're impressed
with how well physics has done so far I
think we're both pretty impressed with
with with how well physics has done so
far we're both impressed but also as
David was saying I mean a response to
Chris's question following out his line
of inquiry right following out his
project was leading him to things that
would be you know quite extraordinarily
new let me say if you if you said you
know these knotted topological structure
and they're gonna be the foundation of
that it's got to be field theoretic I
mean right we don't
that's not stuff you're finding in
physics and stuff that would physics
wouldn't have to imagine the phrase this
question is precisely because it's
coming up in other areas of physics now
but yeah that yeah that but I mean I
don't I don't but I'm sorry we both cut
you off before either of us understood
your question
you mean if I'm buying into what to what
Tim referred to what say some
continental philosophers refer to as the
spatialization of yes I'm buying into
that more than Timmons that that seems
like a fair that seems like a fair
distinction yes yeah
right okay this is now Tenma's view yeah
yeah I agree with I think I can actually
just make a quick comment here um the
actual practice of physics and science
in general I don't think David's going
to disagree about this when scientists
set out to write a paper saying I'm
going to explain this or you know they
always treat sure the time direction in
a certain way sure right and they talk
about initial conditions and later
things and this causing that and so on
so it's not as if looking at scientific
practice right there's there's all kinds
of what look like depending on the
direction of time being there and
playing a certain kind of role in some
you know in in in producing explanations
but do something about it practice if
there's supposed to be something about
that practice that indicates no they're
treating that direction was fun no I'm
not sound I'm saying no I'm saying it's
neutral in that sense it's neutral right
between us
right right right not not not that it's
on my side I'm saying it's it's neutral
but I agree so I'm not saying oh ignore
what science is tough I mean it sounded
like you were saying David saying listen
to science and ignore it and I'm saying
no-no-no not intuitive at all look the
fundamentality of time of time structure
I mean there's nothing intuitive about
the time structure of relativity which
is what I ended up with it's actually
very unintuitive right no I mean no
people don't grow up thinking
relativistically at all so I'm not
appealing in that sense what the actual
structure is I'm not saying gee just
trust your intuitions or anything like
that
but what I said was that the world is
presented to us as I mean experience is
not a word I like to get into I mean
because I don't know how to explain
anybody's experience of anything and
David made clear he really talks about
experience but doesn't mean conscious
experience I mean we're all caught with
the mind-body problem right right what I
talked about was the way the world is
presented you know as it were initially
presented way we would describe it and
that's not about my experience it's
about like saying oh it's when I say
space is three-dimensional that on the
face of it is not a claim about my
experience of anything it's a claim
about space right
yeah yes I mean it's different from
space in that I look there the the there
is no that when I say everybody people
seem so amazing people say look there's
no point crying over spilled milk
that's a temporally directed comment
right I mean there there is a point in
being careful not to spill your milk
right if you haven't spilled it yet but
there's no point in crying over it once
it's done okay that's just you know that
sort of simple thing that everybody
understands has a temporal asymmetry
embedded in it it's one we're all
familiar with
taking climate on fundamental as somehow
well it's serving its lesson metaphysics
first right and it might be structure
and then let's build up and explain how
experience works from there whereas or
how we experience I mean all these
features of you know the temporal
aspects of our language and explanations
whereas something like the converse is
going on that you might be inclined to
be us somehow more I don't maybe more
economical or you're not pleasant your
there's no sort of metaphysical
primitive involved in in
and or it doesn't seem to me that there
is you're relying money just as a bank
adjust the mechanics and characterizing
how the appearance and the the temporal
aspects of our language follow from that
while doing some explanation posterior
explanation of these other features like
a symmetry and epistemic access through
these other means I I'm inclined to
think that that that's a nice unifying
view in it and it doesn't require like
the same kind of I mean I I think David
put it pretty well but I don't think it
maps on to what you just said David
thinks dynamics first geometry derived I
think the geometry constrains the
dynamics right so I mean imagine
somebody says somebody says having just
learned special relativity and they say
really the fundamental what is the
fundamental postulate of special
relativity it's a possible about the
geometrical structure of space-time it's
been coughs key structure and then you
say now you're gonna write I haven't
said a word about dynamics and now I say
now I'm gonna write down some dynamics I
said well you know you're gonna be
really constrained because you better be
able to express your dynamics using only
that structure whatever you write down
mathematically if that's all the
structure there is if that's all the
space-time structure there is then of
course your dynamics however you express
it better be expressed solely in terms
of that structure so that's the kind of
geometry constrains dynamics now David
wanted to say dynamics produces geometry
and what constrains his dynamics was
this very very very weak thing I mean
that was what this discussion was about
I don't see either of these as being
more or less metaphysics II than the
other I mean we have different starting
points and we you know we're seeing what
happens if you try and I mean David
arrives at a certain thing that Kris was
getting into by taking the dynamics
first I tend to think of the geometry
first and the geometry constraining the
dynamics and I want to write the
dynamics down in terms of fundamental
geometrical structure rather than
deriving the fundamental tree or
geometrical structure from the dynamic
and I don't I just don't see this being
either us being more or less Con Thien
or more even more or less economical
quite honestly exactly I mean maybe
maybe you think there's more to say I
mean the only the the I I don't I think
I agree with almost everything Tim said
the only the only I guess the way I was
presenting it here there's a step that
comes before the dynamics in order to
even begin to talk about dynamics you
need a foliation in two times and then
stand the way you sleep that is you need
to discover that there's a way of Foley
aiding the the arena such that there are
simple rules connecting the leaves once
you've got that you've got a dynamics
and then and then you're off to the to
the rest of it right
I've told maybe I think it's time to
sort out which is which is that when it
comes to saving the phenomenon you're
saying you can't and he's saying I don't
understand that I think we're both I
think the game for both of us is saving
the phenomena oh I don't I thought but I
thought you said in the end you can save
why and what I was the apparent
directionality I mean the appearance is
the phenomena right David sir no one
wants to think he can at the end of the
day explain why yeah there are
asymmetries in the way things are
distributed right right and and why we
say the stuff we do about about time
directionality no I think we both were
both thinking we can save that I think
the I think like tim has been saying the
difference is is where to start and what
to take his permanent and in that way I
mean the way Tim began to set up his
talk was very helpful for this
discussion in that kind of way
yes
and it is very like momentary me would
be put into a problem there because like
so so there's tons of that that went
over my head let me let me start to let
me start to try to unpack it there's oh
by the way in relation to your question
one thing Tim said a couple of times
Oh in the relativistic case you're not
going to get the kind of foliation that
david wants in the in the way that he
wants it I don't think that's true in
the in the difference between a
relativistic theory and a classical
theory one of the differences is going
to be you have this distribution and you
find that there are lots of ways of
cutting up the space that produce these
rules there's an infinite number of ways
that end up corresponding to all of the
space like foliation that's equivalent
of course through the light cone
structure so so no I don't think there's
any I I don't think there's any sense in
which relativity was producing something
other than what I had in mind
about the now when you talk about an
infinite wavefunction I'm not let's see
first of all most of what I was talking
about was just classical physics stuff
so I lost you at the at the infinite
wave and I'm not even sure I know what
an infinite wave function means yeah
yeah that it's one of the things that a
view like mine is going to have to aim
to explain okay
why it is given the symmetry of the
dynamical laws that we have this
measurement or recording type of access
to the past and not to the future and
the the proposal was oh because if you
go towards the past this regress of well
I know this because I have a record of
that and I know that because I have a
record of that bla bla bla bla bla you
need all of these ready Snead all these
things that I was calling ready states
that that you have one handy ultimately
in the past in the form of this past
hypothesis that you need in order to
explain thermodynamics you don't have
one towards the future and that's
supposed to be the beginning of an
account of why we have this kind of
record or measurement type epistemic
access toward the past and not toward
the future right
I surely epistemically ya in the
classical case it's purely epistemic
it's not like I mean uncertainty in
quantum mechanics is a really bad
historical accident because it makes it
sound like it makes it sound like
there's an epistemic issue there whereas
there's well depends on your way of
solving the measurement problem but I'm
the standard presentations of quantum
mechanics on the textbook presentations
of quantum mechanics there's a
metaphysical issue they are not an
epistemic issue classically it seems
appropriate to say there are all kinds
of things about the future of which
we're uncertain it's a lot harder to get
an epistemic purchase on all kinds of
aspects of the future than it is on all
kinds of aspects of the past and yes the
proposal is that what lies behind that
asymmetry is the fact that in one
temporal direction there's a past
hypothesis and in the other there isn't
right
changing that extraction can't exceed
what would happen
in a relativistic theory but I'm not
sure why we're getting into relativity
here I mean maybe there's a good reason
I'm not I'm not sure I mean there's
there's if we want to start talking
about relativistic theories that's right
I'm I don't think the distinction
between relativistic theories and non
relativistic theories was playing any
crucial role in what I was trying to say
I'm sorry I did a really bad job of
figuring out what the question
like the direction of my we should have
superstitions get a light for news fish
inside yourself and only maybe something
and applause
it'll have two water lines which word
this David Wallace use a lot
what instantiate Owen Stan she ate okay
this if this David Wallace use that word
yeah yeah okay yes yes
I mean I'm not sure how much of this I
understood but but but it seems like Tim
wants it to be the case that there are
facts about these lines and there
directedness --is before you start
talking about how mass and matter and
fields are distributed over space-time
that that's in the fundamental structure
of space-time itself and it's it's also
you know it's right that whatever is is
is whatever distinctions there are in
our experience of the world had better
be locatable somewhere in both of our
accounts of the world and in my account
you're in the kind of account that I'm
trying to pursue you're right in saying
it would have to be rooted in the
distribution of matter and and fields
and stuff like that you seem to say say
something further that that's the first
structure that would appear or something
I'm not sure I knew what that meant
which is what okay but now it sounds
like now it sounds like you're talking
about a problem that's specific to
something like every well but I'm not
for example in bone you know there isn't
gonna be an issue like that it's right
you know that the pads are right there
of the particles so I'm not so yeah now
it sounds like you're talking about a a
worry that's specific to something to a
particular way of trying to understand
quantum mechanics and a way that as you
anticipated I think and I think Tim
thinks there are all kinds of other
reasons why it's just not going to pan
out anyway
I just I don't think Everett is going to
pan out as a way of understanding I know
what intrinsically is grw something
that's intrinsically wave mechanics is
boom something that's intrinsic I guess
bomb is supposed to be not something
that's intrinsically where you can well
I don't know whether grw is those lines
are in the GR I mean I'm speaking for
Tim here but those lines are there
before before there's any talk of of
what it is that occupies right space
time I mean what maybe we should you
know nothing really David said her I
said had anything to do with quantum I
mean bringing quantum mechanics on top
of the mess we have enough so yeah
that's already but but but I mean maybe
this maybe this will help in terms of
the difference cuz David said very
directly said alright he was starting
with just this different
four-dimensional differentiable manifold
and then putting stuff on it in a
certain distribution out distributions a
little tricky there because you normally
think of a distribution already as
giving distances and you know various
geometrical relations between topology
so you know it's a it's a something
buddy-buddy but because this four
dimensional manifold he's starting with
makes no distinction as it were between
space and time as he said if he can do
it this way and then on the very same
manifold as it were paint another non
interacting story that way and and
another one that way and that time
directions of all these different
stories would be right pointing in
different ways as it were if we you know
we could compare them locally right on
my picture certainly in the relativistic
case once the fundamental thing Aria is
a single light cone structure built into
it it's there at the most fundamental
geometrical level you can't just then
say Oh add another one that going this
way and add another
going this way no it's you know so he's
working you know he is starting with
something it has a lot less structure
built into it yes that's right and
because it has a lot less structure
built into it there has to be a much
greater story about how the structure
were we think we're familiar with
emerges exactly by some other means or
any-any go way hyperbolic I mean you can
tell the same story for any code yeah
I mean yeah again it's not really I mean
there are lots of lots of proofs that
have been around forever in just
standard gr general relativity what
you're what gets built in on my way of
doing things is what would be called a
conformal structure which is just the
light-cone structure so it's weaker than
Minkowski space-time okay and there are
lots of proofs that go back forever that
basically say the the conformal
structure follows from what's called the
causal structure but the causal
structure is nothing but a partial
ordering among events by earlier and
later that's what the causal structure
is I mean really doesn't have to do with
causation it's a funny word for it it's
really temporal you know it is the order
of the temporal ordering structure
that's input implicit in a general
relativistic space so yeah there are
lots of I mean those theorems have been
around forever they're not due to me and
I can just wave at them basically you
know and say see
yeah yeah Chris Chris actually knows the
history of that better than I do but
fruitful yet challenging discussion on a
very difficult topic so thanks a lot